welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in one division's first two
episodes leave one thing clear
something is very wrong in west view too
many smiles too many chants for
for the children that voice over the
radio we think jimmy wu
put it best
yes who is doing this to wanda well i'm
going to break down the top five
suspects of who
the real villain of wanda vision is
spoiler warning in case i'm right oh and
this video is brought to you by remote
hq the platform that allows teams to
work together as if they were in the
same room even when they're not
let's start with agnes catherine han's
nosy neighbor consume enough true crime
podcasts or episodes of svu
and it's always a nosy neighbor we have
been speculating for months that agnes
is an adaptation of
agava harkness the witch in the marvel
comics who poses as a friend in
babysitter for wanda
when she suddenly shows up with children
every line out of agnes's mouth sounds
like it has a duplicitous agenda
wanda charmed or maybe i could just be
myself
more or less
oh wanda and then she has that randomly
tense moment with the mailman
morning agnes stick him up oh
don't shoot i'm just a messenger
it's as if she doesn't want any messages
getting in or out of west view
and then there's that pendant that she
shows up both in episode one and episode
two wearing that if you zoom in on it
looks like there's three figures one in
the middle that could be some kind of
demonic entity maybe
death a grim reaper mephisto with two
smaller people behind it could be two
children
perhaps for her master mephisto using
pieces of his soul to puppet these two
children
agnes barges into the house at random
times even coming through the door in
the episode 2
animated intro despite all the other
neighbors having to wave in through the
window and she also
just seems way too in division as wanda
shuts her out
and the supermarket is a sign for auntie
a's kitty litter which could be a nod to
auntie agnes auntie agatha
who has a black cat named ebony in the
comics and then agnes says this
mysterious off-screen husband
ralph who she never shuts up about the
only way ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beard
named june
2nd and let me tell you what ralph could
really use is
how to goose your wife so you don't lose
your wife
not that ralph ever wants to eat
anything other than baked beans are you
sure you don't want an audience
volunteer named
my husband ralph oh and then she
misdirects wanda to a different enemy
dottie dropping this line the devil's in
the details bev
that's not the only place he is a devil
and that brings us to our second suspect
mephisto mephisto is the devil in the
marvel comics the demonic overlord whom
agatha serves
in that comic series i mentioned wanda's
children are revealed to be
puppets of actually an intermediary
figure master pandemonium but he is
using pieces of methisto's soul to
manifest these children
to trick wanda into having her chaos
magic drained from her agatha ends up
gaslighting wanda into forgetting this
ever happened oh this is gonna be a gap
so mephisto could be this devil in the
details that agnes was referring to
ralph could be her name for mepisto
especially when you consider her
anniversary date
the only way ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beer named
june 2nd june 2nd is the date the salem
witch trials began
in 1692 and then there's agnes pet
rabbit
senor scratchy who was sacrilegiously
cast as baby jesus
in the christmas pageant and mr scratch
or old scratch is a nickname for the
devil
senor scratch he's got real star quality
don't you think
and then there's this recurring color
red on the show often in a negative
context from the beeping red light on
the start toaster to the blood on
dottie's hand
the mysterious helicopter toy and that
big red gum that clogs vision's gears
this could be a reflection of wanda's
famously scarlet tinted chaos magic
or all of it the magic included could
all root back to that same demonic place
and then there's a recurring number six
motif the six
pointed hexagons in the closing wipes of
episodes one and two
the six star constellation the missing
six from the clock radio
you put too many sixes together and you
know that spells evil and speaking of
red
there's the red herring villain that the
series wants us to look at
suspect three the beekeeper the guy who
climbs out of the manhole he's got that
sword logo on the back of his suit
now this actor is zach henry he's from
the show's stunt team and he's a
returning stunt performer from several
marvel productions
the fact that he is from sword though
and you see him entering that pocket
reality and the featurette footage tells
me that he is more likely another agent
of sword alongside monica rambo who's
just trying to probe this reality and
help save wanda probably not a bad guy
looking to do harm
but for those not convinced of my
mephistomofistance
we also can make a case that another
villain for marvel comics could be at
play here and again thanks to remote hq
for sponsoring this video remote hq is a
high security collaborative workspace
that lets remote teams work together in
ways that are not possible with other
tools they let
you and your team work together as if
you're in the same room even if they're
all at home
or in a tent pitch next to a starbucks
with good wi-fi
the platform is browser-based so there's
nothing to download the feature we
really love at new rockstars is that the
workspace is customizable and you can
mix
and match apps for any use we can play a
youtube video or open chrome or dropbox
and edit a google doc
all while seeing and talking to each
other it's so great remote hq
automatically captures and logs notes
for every event into a searchable trail
which is so nice to be able to just
go back and find exactly what you were
talking about like when offscreen
producer zach tries to recount the time
he met don cheadle waiting in the ballet
line i can easily search through the
notes of our friday meeting and find the
story and then we all realized that it
wasn't actually that impressive boom
apparently for this head to remote hq
dot com new rock stars for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the code new rockstars for
three months for three that's code new
rockstars for three months free at
remotehq.com
new rockstars suspect for the grim
reaper so the grim reaper is a kind of
tech based villain
in the marvel comics who's later imbued
with dark magic able to reanimate the
dead and transfer souls
the four-pronged helmet of the grim
reaper shows up
in the floorboards of their home in that
episode 2 animated intro
in the comic avengers issue 102 the grim
reaper battles vision in a plot to
transfer vision's mind to the body of
wonder man the grim reaper's brother to
try to resurrect his brother another
supermarket sign
reads the word wonder maybe a nod to
wonder man
and in episode 1 their license plate is
0102 maybe a nod to avengers 102.
there's also their stage names in
episode two glamour and illusion nods to
these zarkov stage names
glamour and illusion in a 12 issue run
in the 80s that does kind of tie into
the grim reaper when wanda and vision
are living in a new jersey town
the area code on their real estate sign
in the show is for new jersey and a
character mentions hackensack new jersey
but we might be thinking about this all
wrong folks because in some of the best
mysteries the villain
is actually the point of view character
themselves so suspect number five wanda
herself
so it all depends on what the true
purpose of this one division series
is is it to help wanda recover from her
losses
or to further her downward spiral of
grief to set her up as a broken villain
in future marvel titles like doctor
trains the multiverse of madness
sword seems pretty convinced that
someone else is doing this to wanda but
dottie places the blame squarely on
wanda herself
i've heard things about you i don't
believe you
and it is wanda who says no and rewinds
away from that sword beekeeper
seemingly in control of this illusion
some have said that you can see wanda
kind of waving her fingers the moment
arthur
chokes as if she was cutting off his
incessant questions but
i i don't know she's kind of twitching
her fingers that whole time it's not
just the moment arthur begins to choke
but ultimately in terms of who
is the true villain of wandavision it's
probably some kind of mix
right wanda has some control over this
illusion but not
full cognition she appears to be under
some kind of charm by
agnes and agnes we can assume is serving
some greater demonic entity
methisto the grim reaper maybe a
combination of the two or someone else
entirely some terrifying voice from
below
by the way i am wearing our new latest
obsession
shirt an unusual couple this thing is
amazing it has secret easter eggs
revealed via augmented reality
you can get this shirt at
newrockstarsmerge.com but you gotta move
fast because we're selling out quickly
at these once we're all sold out back in
the blue dungeon vault they go but when
you do get this
you'll get the added opportunity to
write in a custom shout out that we will
feature in our friday episodes of inside
marvel again that is
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars subscribe
for breakdowns of the many many
questions you still have about
wandavision thank you for watching
buffisto
[Music]
you